David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 9-40A: Mrs. Milgram. Spool 9-40B will be reproduced on a separate spool. 9-40B is the little daughter of Mrs. Fania Freilich, Esther Freilich. It is a short spool, but we are putting it separate.
David Boder: This is Spool 40. August 9th, 1946, Paris, 9 Rue de Patin, and Frau, eh, Mrs. Mira Milgram continues the interview.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Frau Milgram, Sie sind, äh, Sie haben mit dem Gestapo-Mann gesprochen, ob man die Kinder [unverständliches Wort; könnte durchnehmen heißen] wird.
Mira Milgram: Da hat er mir erklärt...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Dass er auch Kinder hat?
Mira Milgram: . . . dass er auch Kinder hat, und sie sind alles Opfer. Ich war mir direkt lächerlich, dass er mich sehr arg berügt, habe ihm erklärt, dass ich einen Bruder mithabe, Verwandte, und so weiter...
David Boder: Wo haben sie Ihren Bruder mitgehabt?
Mira Milgram: Ich hab meinen Bruder im, äh, Lager mitgehabt, meine Cousine und noch drei Personen. Wir waren acht Personen zusammen. Mein Bruder ist während des Aufstandes zu mir gekommen.
David Boder: Aha, ja, und die anderen. Und hat ihr Bruder als Jude gelebt?
Mira Milgram: Nein, arisch!
David Boder: Arier.
Mira Milgram: Arisch. [Unverständliches Wort].
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Mira Milgram: Hat auch sehr viel durchgemacht, wurde einige Male [unverständliches Wort; könnte vielleicht „schikaniert“ heißen].
David Boder: Ja. Also, Sie haben, Sie waren dann die acht Personen zusammen. Wer waren sie, ihr Bruder, ihre...?
Mira Milgram: Mein Bruder, die zwei Kinder, eine Freundin...
David Boder: Ja. Und Sie selbst, das sind fünf...
Mira Milgram: Fünf. Äh, dann war eine Bekannte mit ihrem Sohn...
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: . . . eine Arierin, und noch eine Freundin von mir.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Mira Milgram: [Unverständlicher Satz]. Äh, Gestapo-Mann, also, ich heiße Bernhard nach dem Vornamen. Beten Sie für mich und es wird alles gut sein.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Ich hab ihn direkt ausgelacht. Geh von ihm weg, nach einer Stunde in [unverständliches Wort]
David Boder: Hat der Gestapo-Mann Polnisch gesprochen?
Mira Milgram: Nein, Deutsch. Aber damals war ich schon so aufgeregt, dass es mir schon alles eins war, und auf seine Frage, wieso ich Deutsch spreche, habe ich ihm erklärt, ich bin aus Posen...
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: . . . und darum spreche ich Deutsch.
Mira Milgram: Und wie er zur Segregation kommt, sagte sie, dass er die Segregation durchführt. Er zeigt auf rechts oder links, die Rechten fahren nach Deutschland zu den Konzentrationslagern, links war zum Verbleib.
David Boder: Zu was?
Mira Milgram: Zum Verbleib im Gouvernement.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Und wie ich auf ihn zukomme, sagt er mir wie glauben Sie wird es in [unverständliches Wort] und auf diese Weise hab ich durchgeführt alle acht Personen.
David Boder: Wohin, nach Deutschland?
Mira Milgram: Nein, eben...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Nach Hause.
Mira Milgram: . . . zum Verbleib...
David Boder: im Gouvernement.
Mira Milgram: . . . im Gouvernement. Man hat uns dort gebracht in ein anderes Lager, und dort den nächsten Tag mit der Bahn nach Kielce gebracht.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: In Kielce waren wir bis zum 16. Januar, bis zum Tage, wo sie deutsch, äh, die russische Armee mitsamt der polnischen...
David Boder: befreit hat.
Mira Milgram: befreit hat.
David Boder: Also, in Kielce waren Sie frei in der Stadt, oder...
Mira Milgram: [unterbricht] Ja, wir haben gewohnt, ich hatte schon eine Wohnung dort...
David Boder: Wovon haben Sie denn gelebt?
Mira Milgram: Ähm, ich habe wieder verdient.
David Boder: Als was?
Mira Milgram: Ich habe gehandelt.
David Boder: Gehandelt.
Mira Milgram: Ja.
David Boder: Schnaps?
Mira Milgram: Nein, so nicht, dort konnte ich schon nicht mit Schnaps. Dort habe ich mit Sachen gehandelt.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Und die jüngsten zwei Tage vor der Befreiung waren die Ärgsten für mich...
David Boder: Warum?
Mira Milgram: Nämlich, die ersten Kugeln trafen das Haus, wo ich gewohnt habe. Die Wohnung ist abgebrannt...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Brannt.
Mira Milgram: und ich...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Das war [unverständliches Wort] nicht wahr?
Mira Milgram: Nein, das waren...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Kanonen.
Mira Milgram: . . . von Kanonen.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Und ich befand mich wieder mit der ganzen Familie mit zwei kleinen Kindern auf der Straße.
Mira Milgram: Wir waren in eine nahe Wohnung, in der Deutsche gewohnt haben, hereingegangen. Aber die erste Zeit war schrecklich, man konnte kein Brot bekommen, nicht. Da konnte...Ich bin Tag für Tag drei Tage nach Befreiung von Katowice in Katowice, wo ich mir ein bisschen Lebensmittel für die Kinder gewechselt habe.
David Boder: Katowice, das ist grad über Sosnowiec, nicht wahr?
Mira Milgram: Ja, ja, ja.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Mira Milgram: Nun, so ging, dass mir die polnische Armee, es waren dort jüdische Soldaten, die erfahren hatten, dass Kinder, jüdische, in der Stadt sind. Die haben mir sehr geholfen. Das waren die einzigen Kinder in der Stadt jüdische.
David Boder: In Kielce.
Mira Milgram: Ja, in Kielce.
David Boder: Nun?
Mira Milgram: Mein Bruder wurde zum Präsident von...
David Boder: Kielce?
Mira Milgram: Kielce und...
David Boder: Was war Ihr Bruder von Beruf?
Mira Milgram: Mein Bruder war Rechtsanwalt.
David Boder: Er war ein Advokat, nicht wahr?
Mira Milgram: In Lemberg, Advokat in Lemberg.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Und wurde zum Vorsteher von Kielce und Umgebung ernannt.
David Boder: Ja. Ja. Nun sagen Sie mal, äh, und dann sind Sie befreit geworden.
Mira Milgram: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann sind Sie. Wohin sind Sie gegangen, und was war die letzte Geschichte, wieweit Sie wissen, von Kielce? Was hat dort in Kielce richtig passiert? Und woher wissen Sie’s?
Mira Milgram: Mein Bruder, wie ich schon gesagt habe, war Präsident dort. Ich bin vor einem halben Jahr nach Warschau übergesiedelt.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Wo ich gearbeitet habe.
David Boder: Als was?
Mira Milgram: Ich habe in einer, äh, Firma, in einer privaten Firma gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Mira Milgram: Habe dabei, habe auch in der zionistischen Organisation gearbeitet, in Jugend. Und die Organisation hat mir ermöglicht, einen Pass und das Visum zu bekommen.
David Boder: Wohin?
Mira Milgram: Nach [unverständliches Wort; vielleicht „Paris“] mit, damit dass ich von hier nach Palästina weiterfahren werde.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Mein Mann war auch Zionist, hat sehr viel gearbeitet als Zionist. Mein Bruder auch.
David Boder: Und?
Mira Milgram: Vor paar Tagen, vor, äh, äh, einen Tag nach dem jüdischen Pogrom fahre ich mit der Elektrischen und sehe auf einmal in der Zeitung...
David Boder: Welches Pogrom [unverständliches Wort]. In Kielce?
Mira Milgram: In Kielce.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Dass da Pogrom...dass dort ein Pogrom war. Ich war sofort sicher, dass meinen Bruder nicht lebt, denn ich habe ihn gekannt als einen Mann, der vor nicht geschreckt, abgeschreckt hat. Außerdem wusste ich, dass er mir sofort Kunde gegeben hätte, wenn er wusste wie viel wir aneinander gehangen hatten. Wir hatten ja niemanden anderen.
Mira Milgram: Nur ihn.
David Boder: Nun.
Mira Milgram: Hat mir auch sehr finanziell geholfen. Und...[unverständliches Wort]...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Und was haben Sie in der Zeitung erfahren?
Mira Milgram: Dass dort ein Pogrom war.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Ich bin sofort zur Post. Habe antelefoniert die Miliz. Dort hat man mir erzählt, die wissen noch nichts Bestimmtes, aber ich soll auf alles vorbereitet sein. Und da wusste ich schon, dass was geschieht.
David Boder: Sie haben angerufen die Kielce-Miliz?
Mira Milgram: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Mira Milgram: Nun bin den nächsten Tag nach Kielce gefahren. Mit dem Auto.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Das war was Schreckliches. Nämlich unterwegs fast nur Intelligenz gefahren, haben derart über den Pogrom gesprochen, und wie ich herausgestiegen bin, ich denen zugerufen habe, ihr seid Vieher.
David Boder: Ihr seid was?
Mira Milgram: Vieher.
David Boder: Vieh!
Mira Milgram: Ihr seid Vieh.
David Boder: Verstehe.
Mira Milgram: Ja. Nämlich man sprach davon so, als wenn man zugeschaut hätte, wie man einen Hund umbringt.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Mit Gelächter.
David Boder: Und das waren Polen?
Mira Milgram: Das waren Polen, unter anderem ein Geistlicher aus Kielce.
David Boder: Wieso, Sie sind doch nach Kielce gefahren?
Mira Milgram: Ich bin nach Kielce gefahren...
David Boder: . . . und Sie haben Leute getroffen, die schon von Kielce waren?
Mira Milgram: Nein, nein, die überhaupt darüber gesprochen haben.
David Boder: Ja. Ja. Nun?
Mira Milgram: Das war das Schreckliche. Ja, die Zivil, Zivilbevölkerung.
David Boder: Ja. Nicht Besoffene?
Mira Milgram: Derart...
David Boder: Ja. Nun? Und was haben Sie in Kielce...
Mira Milgram: [spricht über Interviewer]...geärgert.
David Boder: . . . gefunden?
Mira Milgram: In Kielce habe ich erfahren, dass mein Bruder von neun Uhr früh herumgerannt ist und in der Stadt war, bei der Miliz, und so weiter, und gebeten hat um Hilfe. Nämlich die haben schon gewusst, dass sich etwas dort tun wird.
David Boder: Oh, die Miliz hat gewusst?
Mira Milgram: Ja.
David Boder: War die Miliz alles polnisch, waren da keine jüdischen Leute in der Miliz?
Mira Milgram: Nein. Das waren vielleicht ein oder zwei, nur sie hatten nicht dort [unverständliches Wort].
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Und, mein Bruder, der in der Stadt war, ist zu seinen Juden zurückgegangen. Er wollte sie nicht zurücklassen. Ob zwar weiß hat er in Kielce auf arischen Papieren gewohnt hat.
David Boder: Oh, er hat, war in Kielce statthaft als Arier?
Mira Milgram: Ja, nein, er war nur in seinem Komitee, war er Jude. Doktor [unverständlicher Name], und in seiner Wohnung hat er gewohnt als [unverständlicher Name], das war sein Name der Konspiration. Er hat nämlich die ganze Zeit in Konspiration gearbeitet.
David Boder: Aber sie sagen, er war Bürgermeister in Kielce?
Mira Milgram: Nicht Bürgermeister.
David Boder: Was denn?
Mira Milgram: Er war Präsident der Gem-, der jüdischen Gemeinde.
David Boder: Oh, er war Präsident der jüdischen Gemeinde, ach so. Er wurde für den Präsident der jüdischen Gemeinde, ja.
Mira Milgram: Ja. Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, sagen Sie mal, was war denn eigentlich dort während dem Pogrom, man hat etwas gelesen. Wie, was waren die Einzelheiten?
Mira Milgram: Also, es gesch...in der Stadt wurde die Nachricht kolportiert, es fehlen elf Kinder. Und dass Juden sie getötet haben, um Blut von ihnen für die...Juden, die aus Russland kommen, und die sehr schlecht ausschauen...
David Boder: Aha.
Mira Milgram: . . . und sehr aus...äh...
David Boder: Ausgehungert sind.
Mira Milgram: . . . ausgehungert sind. Und für die das Blut der arischen Kinder zu nehmen.
David Boder: Oh, man hat nicht mal gesagt [schwer zu verstehen; könnte „Mazzot“ heißen].
Mira Milgram: Nein, nein, nein. Es ist ja jetzt nicht die Zeit.
David Boder: Welchen Monat...
Mira Milgram: Ostern nicht?
David Boder: Ja. Welchen Monat war es ungefähr?
Mira Milgram: Das war am 4. Juli.
David Boder: Juli. Ja. Also man hat gesagt, dass sie das Blut für die kranken Juden brauchen.
Mira Milgram: Für die kranken Juden brauchen, die aus Russland kommen.
David Boder: Kommen, nun.
Mira Milgram: Und es wurde ein Bub untergestellt, der erklärt hat, dass ihn die Juden paar Tage im Keller des jüdischen Komitee gehalten haben.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Dabei hat sich gezeigt, dass dort überhaupt kein Keller da war.
Mira Milgram: Der Bub hat das ge-, erklärt schon den Tag vorher auf das Miliz.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Und die haben das laufen lassen.
Mira Milgram: Und den nächsten Tag von neun Uhr früh haben sich Leute zusammengeschart vor dem Haus wo die jüdische Gemeinde war, wo die Alten gewohnt haben.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Und dann ist die Miliz gekommen, hat abgesperrt das Haus.
Mira Milgram: Hat verlangt, dass alle ihre, äh...
David Boder: Waffen.
Mira Milgram: Waffen abgeben.
David Boder: Von der jüdischen Gemeinde?
Mira Milgram: Von der jüdischen Gemeinde.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Weil man in der Stadt sagte, dass Juden schießen, und man daran nicht Schuld, äh, nicht das zulassen will...
Mira Milgram: Dass man, dass, äh, man das sagt, nicht wahr...
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Weil es nicht wahr ist.
Mira Milgram: Und wie der letzte Jude die Waffe abgegeben hat, haben die angefangen, mit diesen Waffen zu die Juden zu schießen, sie zu schlagen und so weiter. Man hat dort geraubt. Mein Bruder, der zu ihnen gesprochen hat, und sie gebeten hat, sie sollen Ruhe geben. [Klopfen/ Unterbrechung]
David Boder: . . . der zu den Leuten gesprochen hat, ja?
Mira Milgram: Der ihnen [unverständliches Satzende]. Das wird ja nicht so trocken abgehen.
David Boder: Ja. Die Miliz.
Mira Milgram: Zur Miliz.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Dann ist auch Militär zugekommen.
David Boder: Polnisches Militär.
Mira Milgram: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Mira Milgram: Hat zu denen gesagt: Ihr müsst mit euch, äh...
David Boder: Muss sich verteidigen?
Mira Milgram: Müsst, müsst für euch, äh...[spricht Polnisch]
David Boder: Was sagen Sie Polnisch?
Mira Milgram: [spricht Polnisch] Ihr müsst aufpassen, was ihr macht.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Das wird ja nicht trocken abgehen.
David Boder: Die Militär hat gesagt zu wem, zu den Juden?
Mira Milgram: Mein Bruder hat es zu ihnen gesagt.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Wir, die ganze Welt wird herschreien: Was macht ihr hier? Hat man ihn auch dann erschossen, und er war der einzige, der erschossen wurde, denn den Rest hat man gemordet auf schreckliche Weise. Eine Frau, die im achten Monat war, hat man vom zweiten Stock heruntergeworfen, und auf Bajonette. Und das gibt...
David Boder: Wer hatte Bajonette, die Soldaten?
Mira Milgram: Die Soldaten sind unten.
David Boder: Nun, [unverständliches Wort] sagen Sie doch, [unverständliches Wort].
Mira Milgram: Also, die Soldaten sind unten gestanden. Die Soldaten haben dann später erklärt, dass sie gewusst haben, wozu sie geschickt wurden. Sie haben erfahren von dort, wie sie die, als zum Haus gekommen sind, dass Juden arische Kinder...
David Boder: Vernichten.
Mira Milgram: Ermordet haben.
David Boder: Ermordet haben. Waren da keine Offiziere?
Mira Milgram: Waren Offiziere. Meinen Mann, äh, meinen Bruder hat ein Major.
David Boder: Ein Major hat ihn. Wurde er bestraft?
Mira Milgram: Das. Ich bin dabei gleich von Polen weggefahren.
David Boder: Sie sind gleich von Polen weggefahren.
Mira Milgram: Nach drei Tagen habe ich Polen verlassen. Ich konnte direkt nicht mehr dort bleiben. [Unverständlicher Satzanfang] ich es nicht.. Man hat....
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Man hat dort fünf Personen derart massakriert, dass man nicht gewusst hat, ob es eine Frau oder ein Mann ist. Man hat sie nicht erkannt, man weiß nicht, wer das ist. Es wurden 40 Leute erschlagen, und zwei kleine Kinder.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, was hat nachher die, hat nachher die polnische Regierung getan.
Mira Milgram: Die polnische Regierung hat alles getan, was sie konnte.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Das Pogrom hat gedauert von neun Uhr früh bis fünf Uhr nachmittags.
Mira Milgram: Man hat Leute aus dem Zug herausgezogen, aus Wohnungen, und so weiter. Die Regierung hat Leute aus Warschau geschickt. Man hat ein...äh, man hat ein Standgericht eingerichtet.
David Boder: Ja. Ja.
Mira Milgram: Polizeistunde und so weiter. Aber das Ärgste ist, dass die Leute wirklich dran geglaubt haben, dass die Juden die Kinder getötet haben, und dass nicht nur...
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: . . . die, das hat da, daran hat sogar die Intelligenz.
David Boder: Die Intelligenz...
Mira Milgram: Ja. Denn ich habe selber mit Intelligenten gesprochen, die mir gesagt haben etwas musste daran sein.
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Und wie ich ihnen erklärt habe, nur wo sind die Kinder. Man hat ja jetzt das Haus zugenagelt, nicht wahr. Zeigt mir eine Mutter, der das Kind fehlt. Darauf habe ich keine Antwort.
David Boder: Also die allgemeine Stimmung in Polen, was Juden anbetrifft, ist was?
Mira Milgram: Hitler hat zu lange dort gearbeitet. Es ist ein wortloser Antisemitismus. Die Juden haben Angst, dort zu sein. Und meiner Meinung nach haben die Juden so viel verrichtet, dass sie wirklich verdienen, in Ruhe gelassen zu werden. Ich weiß selber. [Unverständlicher Satz] Ich habe dort die Schule besucht, ich habe Universität studiert, ich habe Freunde zwischen den Polen. Aber ich hab mich nicht gut gefühlt, ich hatte Angst. Ich bin der Meinung, nach Jahren wird sich das vielleicht bessern. Aber jetzt ist der Platz der Juden nicht hier. Die Regierung macht so was wieder, die Regierung geht nicht an [unverständliches Wort].
David Boder: Ja.
Mira Milgram: Aber die Bevölkerung, das [unverständliches Wort].
David Boder: Frau Milgram, und Sie wollen denn jetzt nach Palästina gehen. Und Sie wollen...
Mira Milgram: [unterbricht] Das ist mein einziger Wunsch jetzt. Ich will mein Kind in Palästina erziehen. Denn...
David Boder: Aber dann, ja?
Mira Milgram: Sein Vater war Zionist, der Kleine ist Zionist, er hat nur das eine [unverständliches Wort] in Palästina [unverständliches Satzende].
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, dass das, dass das Kind katholische Religion unterrichtet war, hat das nicht in irgendeiner Weise...
Mira Milgram: Aber es hat alles vergessen, es ist ein heißer Jude, und...
David Boder: Aber für eine kurze Zeit hat er nicht wirklich polnisch gebetet, katholisch...
Mira Milgram: Nein, nie.
David Boder: Und er hat die ganze Rolle gespielt...
Mira Milgram: Er hat die ganze Rolle als fünfjähriges Kind gespielt, dass man darin kann wirklich glauben.
David Boder: Und hat gewusst, dass er nicht die Wahrheit...
Mira Milgram: Er hat alles gewusst. Alles überhaupt, er spricht wenig, jetzt aber. Er sieht viel...
David Boder: Spricht wenig.
Mira Milgram: . . . und spricht wenig.
David Boder: Nun ja, sagen Sie aber, Frau Milgram, es ist ja auch jetzt in Palästina nicht ganz ruhig. Was denken Sie davon?
Mira Milgram: Ich will schon eher dort unbeliebt sein wie in einem andern, an einem andern Ort beliebt. Dort weiß ich wenigstens, wofür ich kämpfen werde, wenn ich mitgehe. In Polen wusste ich das nicht.
David Boder: Na ja. Danke sehr, Frau Milgram. Will vielleicht der Junge etwas sagen? No? Alright.
Mira Milgram: Er wird vielleicht [unverständliches Satzende].
David Boder: Hat er eine Familie in Amerika, haben Sie Familie in Amerika?
Mira Milgram: In Amerika auch.
David Boder: [In English] This concl—
David Boder: I am taking now for a short statement eh, Esther, eh, Esther Frieden...
Esther Freilich: Freilich.
David Boder: Esther Freilich, whose mother has covered Spool 36, 37 and 38. Esther is 13 years old.
David Boder: This concludes Spool 9-40A. The interview with Mrs. Milgram. 9-40B is a separate spool, and has the interview with Esther Freilich, the daughter of Mrs. Frieda Freilich. Boder. Now...